What does everyone on the planet said?
No to their gas powered car
right now and not just cars,
gas dryers, water heater's,
gas stoves, lawn mowers.
What if we stop burning
fossil fuels all at once?
Would this make our lives
that much more inconvenient?
What would happen to the climate?
Could it help us beat global warming?
This is what f and here's what would
happen if we stop burning fossil fuels
right now.
So you probably know that fossil
fuels are spewing carbon dioxide.
Indoor air co two stays in our atmosphere
and heats up the earth's surface.
But the greenhouse effect,
the main cause of that climate change,
everyone's talking about the earth is
an average of one degree hotter than it
was in the 1880s before our factories
started belting greenhouse gases into the
air doesn't seem that bad.
Well,
it only took a four degree increased to
put an end to the most recent ice age
12,000 years ago
with all our power plants,
cars and appliances. We humans are the
main cause of today's global warming.
What if we banded together and eliminated
the use of fossil fuels once and for
all? Would this be the
solution to climate change?
Want to know what life would be like if
we stop burning fossil fuels right now?
First off, there would be no
transportation, no cars, no
trains, no planes, no ships,
nothing.
Your local grocery store,
it wouldn't get fresh food delivered
for you to buy your electric car would
likely be useless to y.
But just think about where your
electricity comes from. Did you?
No more than two thirds of the world's
electricity production comes from burning
fossil fuels.
So there would be no electricity,
not quite with one third of electric
power generated by renewables and nuclear
stations. We wouldn't go
completely electricity free.
The party would still be going strong
in countries like Costa Rica, Norway,
and Iceland, they run almost exclusively
on renewable power. So head there,
if you need to charge your phone,
the fossil fuel industries
would cease to exist.
So with their $5 trillion
of annual revenue,
it's not just large energy producers like
Russian Gazprom or American Exxon who
would go bankrupt.
Millions of people are employed in those
industries who would lose their jobs.
Coal miners may want to get some
training in solar panel installation,
say goodbye to plastics and a
lot of your favorite gadgets.
Since plastic has made from oil and gas,
we wouldn't be making any more new toys.
Eliminating a stable and cheap source
of energy right now seems a bit extreme.
What's more, it wouldn't solve our climate
change problem. Not In the short term.
The global warming we've already
inflicted on our planet is irreversible.
Even if we stop burning fossil fuels,
the earth would continue warming up for
another few decades because of all the
heat we've already produced.
Global temperatures would climb finally
stabilizing at a level much higher than
we've ever known,
although that's far into the future.
The reality is if we don't
start burning less fossil now,
the result will be devastating.
Luckily, or not, someday we'll run out of
nonrenewable coal, gas, and oil anyway.
Are you ready to rock
some solar panels yet?
How do you help combat climate change?
Okay.